in Florida you're like Rogan like when I
was walking around after doing your pod
everybody's I just saw you on PVD and
that was the same thing after I did
Rogan like the first time just walking
around people like oh I just saw
your Rogan et cetera and but I feel like
happens is every time you bubble out of
that right
you're gonna get the scrutiny of the
casuals right the people who don't
really know you don't know your
experience don't know your story they
start hearing about you and they're
going to have resentment or animosity
for your opinions that are different and
then they start attacking you for the
things you said and you said
some people would go very wild things
some people would also say that's very
rational your take right depending on
your like politics but I feel like when
you offered Tucker the 100 million right
that was outside of bubble did you feel
some heat after that oh absolutely Big
Time absolutely what did people say oh
yeah listen you want to dance I love it
I love it oh my God I can't even
describe it to you like I get excited
when I even think about what that's
going to look like you know look for me
uh everybody fights in a different way
okay there's different styles to
fighting uh you know when when you have
a fighting style where you know Larry
Holmes Versus Ali versus you know you
know all the Ken Norton versus you know
Foreman versus you can go and look at
everybody so it's a different style on
how they would fight right I think in
this world of communication there's a
different way to fight
and deliver your message to yet stand
your ground but at the same time
maintain a relationship with the other
individual that is an art it's not easy
to do it's very hard and the way you do
it is by I think what is unattractive is
the following is when you're 100 I'm
right you're wrong you're an idiot
you're a and some people do it
that way I don't think you're opening up
the door to want to have that exchange
but I think if there's an opportunity to
say listen man find some leaks of my
argument what do you think I love that
you do that yeah it's a cool thing maybe
I'm off yeah I'm okay with that if I can
compliment you a bit more not only do
you bring on people that are going to
disagree with you you don't bring on
like punching bags from the other side
that you could just bully in an argument
you bring on smart people who make great
cases and I think that's really cool and
rare in this space
and going off what uh Andrew said about
you get hate from the general audience
that doesn't necessarily know you how
would you describe yourself
to them or to to who to to them everyone
in general well I mean I think it has to
do with how how long like for example
I'm asking him about the story okay the
the the unique story of this building
next door right Mom how he grew up down
the street how far the bike they don't
want him to ride the bike because he
goes the other way October 30th birthday
40 family yesterday's exchange and text
I'm curious about this guy's a product
right I'm curious about him as a human
being but he didn't become who he is
today because of what I've consumed of
him the last five years I want to know
what prompted this guy to be here
unfortunately in America too many times
our judgment is on who this person is
Chelsea Handler makes this video perfect
example Chelsea Handler makes this video
calling out Adam one of our guys and he
she says whoa look at this guy Alpha
trust me you are definitely not an alpha
he gives me the sde energy and trust me
I can tell you for a fact this guy on
Alpha motivation zero you're not Alpha
this is coming from an alpha you're a
zero is what you are so she calls him
out and she talks about the fact that
it's it's incredible to be childless
it's phenomenal to wake up and not have
any kids have sex with anybody want
drink as much alcohol all this she
says video goes viral 50 million views
on Twitter right whatever the number is
okay so the average girl is gonna watch
that and say what that's right screw
that sde I also want to drink and be
able to be with any man I don't want to
have any kids does anybody even want to
have this kind of responsibility in life
I want to be free because we're equal as
men screw them I don't need them great
then you go read her Memoir where she
tells a story about when she was nine
years old
at the age of nine her brother she
describes who was 22 I think they have
six kids total Mom and Dad I think one
was a car salesman it was a good family
six kids
the older brother 22 she calls him my
second father my first boyfriend I was
in love with him in a way of loving my
older brother but he was my world he's
going on a Mountain hiking uh trip his
last words to her was can I wait to see
when I get back the guy dies
climbing a mountain while she's nine
years old
he never comes back
then when he dies
she says my mom and dad lost it the man
I needed next was my dad my dad I didn't
have my dad anymore because he lost his
mind I don't blame him he says in that
moment I realize the pain of losing
someone I love and secondly I saw my dad
the pain he went through of losing his
child
of course I want to have a hard time
with commitment of one and top kids and
get married do you blame her yeah when
you read this story then you're like
okay Chelsea I understand it's easy to
troll her and it's easy for her to troll
other men but we don't know that story
so if somebody from the outside says
who's Patrick David here's a rich guy
he's probably raised in a you know I
remember there was a time in the third
year the insurance company I was paying
comp more than my competitors were a
rumor started circulating saying pass
link to oil money and you know what I do
with that rumor I ran with it I said
you're right I have oil money I can pay
the count of money you can't pay I don't
have oil money man I worked out a 99
cent store in Inglewood by Great Western
Forum 15 years but I love that rumor so
I ran with it so if somebody doesn't
know your story great you can say what
you can say so if I face opposition I
tell them how much you know about me
tell me your story tell me about your
upbringing why did you come to the
conclusion of the opinions that you have
today tell me I remember when this
happened that okay great can I tell you
why I came to this conclusion yes here's
mine is it fair that we have different
reasons why you we came to this
conclusion you got life changing
experience like that as well how about
we respect each other let me make my
case to you you make your case to me
let's see if anybody can persuade the
other person your game with that let's
have a civil conversation so that's
typically what happens when I face
somebody that fully disagrees uh with
some of my views who is fully disagreed
uh I mean it and it's not even P you'd
be amazed they'll come to me and say Hey
you know you're you know you're you're
supportive Trump on what he does and I
see you you're Mac I'm like I've never
worn a MAG hat I'm not a trump guy yeah
I'm a guy that that's the only thing I
don't like about you yeah yeah you're
right about everything else
yeah one thing I got to respect the
group you guys got here has never worn a
mega hat because he doesn't want to
cover that this is the party in your
group I got an email just so everybody's
wondering why I'm dressed like this
these guys run a tide shop emo came in
Pat has to wear three piece suits with
the tie I had to come here 9 30 in the
morning two hours of makeup I didn't
believe that yeah obviously you want to
be president or not yeah I saw the big
Maga flag I saw in your building here
impress the living crap
and by the way it's so bossy to have it
on the window for people that are
walking
and what do they do they pay on it they
love it yeah
[Laughter]
down here
foreign